what makes a genius they all have one
trait in common they were able to spend
extended periods of time in isolation
focused monomonically on their most
valuable project
please turn off your electronic gadgets
not for others but for yourself we
have put this governor on our minds
and you have to the factory that put the
governor on that car the factory is now
you
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some of the
habits that will change
your life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one use the 1991 rule with robin sharma
for the next 90 days your first
90 minutes at work
make it focused on your single most
important project
i'll repeat that again for the next 90
days
the first 90 minutes of your workday
focus
monomaniacally on your single most
valuable project i call it your
game-changing move
so it might be it might be creating a
new piece of code that will
revolutionize the marketplace
it might be a new product that when you
launch it
will fill a need within your industry
that no
peer is currently providing i don't know
what your game-changing move is
but this is your poetry this is your
magnum
opus for the next 90 days so
what most people do is you know people
who are playing at victimhood people who
are in the 95
people who are making excuses about
ordinary results in their life
a lot of them are not doing the things
that would give them legendary results
and what they do is they get to the
office and rather than using
prime time for a activities
they use their best hours watching
dancing cats on whatever it is
whatever the video platform is they
spend their best hours
surfing the internet looking at blogs
they spend their best
hours playing with notifications reading
notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they're distracting themselves
which is just a form of medication
because potential unexpressed turns to
pain
and they're in a lot of pain and it's
subconscious and they haven't done the
work to know it
so really they've created these drugs of
choice like too much email too much web
surfing too much chit chatting too much
looking at funny looking videos that
make them laugh in the moment that make
them feel happy and give them a
short burst of dopamine and maybe a
little bit of serotonin which is the
pleasure neurotran neurotransmitter
and that's how they get through their
day and all i'm saying is
there is so much distraction available
to you out there that if you are not
acutely careful it will dominate your
days what i'm really trying to say is
this
a ritual for you to run and dial in and
hardwire
to the point of automaticity that's the
word the researchers use when a habit
becomes your new normal
over 66 days is the 1991 rule and to
give it to you again so you really
remember it
for the next 90 days your first 90
minutes
create a tight bubble of total focus so
that no one can distract you turn off
your devices put them in a little
plastic bag put some reminders on your
door maybe some post-it notes that this
is my tight bubble of total focus for
the next 90 minutes
tell your team tell your loved ones
maybe get a put a do not disturb
sign on your door they'll laugh and
explain it to them
that for the next 90 days i will spend
90 minutes away from distraction away
from technology
away from interruptions focusing on my
magnum opus
focusing on the genius project that i
want to bring into the world because i
will never mail it in i will always
bring it on
and i'm going to do this for the next 90
minutes and i'm going to optimize it and
iterate it every day and i'm going to
bring
my full bandwidth because what makes a
genius they all have one trait in common
they were able to spend extended periods
of time
in isolation focused monomonically
on their most valuable project habit
number two
grow gradually with dan lok you will not
get to this kind of super productivity
overnight it's not a shortcut but it's
like a muscle
you know first lift five pounds and then
six pounds and ten pounds
and as you gradually grow you'll be
shocked
how much you accomplish compared to most
people because most people don't
accomplish it
and i like to be smart with my time
so i'm answering questions i'm creating
content i'm speaking i'm creating
content
i'm repurposing then i'm going to go
walk the floor
meet with some people bring in some
business accounts relationships right
and then even investment and so a lot of
that of course if it's not got a team
so everything multiplies but for
personal productivity
what you you guys all strive for is the
maximum that
personal productivity first don't try to
be me you'll go nuts
you 100 go nuts be the best version of
you
so if you're closing am i performing the
best
am i often operating at optimal level am
i focused
just do that first and then from there
you know if i'm closing in 60 minutes
can i close at 55 then close at 45
minutes
not rushing but just to see how it goes
be a little more efficient with my time
so you go from there right instead of
trying to
oh see if you do this i have not met
anybody can do what i do so forget it
forget it so don't don't try to do that
it will only create so much stress
when they see i do this and do this and
do this no
it's not a good idea that's why it's
better sometimes
listen to the instruction and see if it
gives you but don't try to copy what i
do
because you're not it's a different
thing you're not at that place
right so i say wear the costume i don't
need to wear a costume
i got it but you wear the costume
because that's where you're at
right but you also doesn't wear costumes
he doesn't need it
she's been used for long like i can
deliver a talk like that
with no script with nothing no
preparation by the way
there's zero population so when i do htc
like facebook video i leave it like five
ten times
i mean so but i could do things where
because i've done it for so long
so it's different so don't try to
attempt make sense
yeah so no gimmick but be the best
version of you just be a little bit more
efficient
a little bit every week make some tweaks
some improvement
right you close that first out good get
the next that's why i challenge you guys
close the first down get the next one
get to the next one
don't sit on it too long like oh yeah
five minutes okay give me five minutes
move on next thing because i need you to
get to that first
10 20 100 sale because by the time you
get to that 30 40 50
that's who you are now you're not trying
to do closing right you know
[Music]
i don't need to but i like to close
i'm closing i'm closing the book yeah
i'm selling a book
20 bucks hi this is dan lok i want to
share with you a
lesson from evan carmichael's new book
build
to serve this section is about making
money from your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that
is significant one that can pay you so
you can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others
and helping even more people you see
money is nothing more than a byproduct
of value creation the more people that
you serve
the more successful that you will be so
to have long-term success it's not just
build a lot or or build to sell or even
build a scale
it is built to serve and this book will
teach you
exactly how to do that habit number
three
take your time to think with jim collins
please
turn off your electronic gadget
not for others but for yourself
effective people take time to think
begin the discipline of putting white
space on your calendar where there's no
phone no no email i was gonna say no
facts but they don't even have that
anymore
uh no twitter no emails no connections
and
engaged in this glorious pockets of
quietude do you think do you know that
rick warden reads a book
every single day a book a day
[Music]
a book a day 365 days a year
you're at a thousand books in three
years habit number four
manage your activities with bob proctor
think of this for a moment
do you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time
exactly the same amount of time figure
it out
you get all there is a hobo
sleeping under a bridge or on a park
bench
that has no material possessions none
does nothing of any constructive nature
that person gets exactly the same amount
of time
as the most productive industrialist
in the world we all get exactly the same
amount of time
so it's what we do with the time that
makes a difference
i want you to think of the number of
time management programs almost everyone
under the sun
has time management programs in fact i
made one one time spent a lot of money
on it
and then i found out it was a dumb
waste of time and money do you know why
time can't be managed i was having
breakfast with earl nightingale one
morning
and it was downtown chicago and i was
going with him on a speaking engagement
and it was early in the morning he said
you want to meet for breakfast
whenever earl night girl said you want
to meet me i was there and i always had
some well-prepared questions
and i remember asking him i said uh how
did you learn how to master time
management
you know we're having breakfast i can
still hear his fork hit the plate
he's what the hell are you talking about
because i've never mastered time
management nobody masters time
management he said time can't be managed
because i merely manage activity and he
took a little card out of his pocket
and he said every night before i go to
bed i write down six most important
things i have to do tomorrow these are
goal achieving activities
and when i wake up that's what i start
working on
and if i don't get them all done i'll
add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six now if i have
three that i didn't get done today that
doesn't mean
i have nine for tomorrow like six plus
these three
those three become part of the six you
have to do the next day
when you wake up you give all your
conscious attention to do those things
see you cannot manage time but you can
manage activity
you can manage your activities make
certain that what you're doing really
makes a difference
make certain that you're spending your
time on
activities that are productive that are
taking you in the direction of your goal
time cannot be managed activities
can and habit number five the last one
before very special bonus clip
is use the 40 rule with david goggins
when you when you're mine this is this
this whole 40 percent rule
i talk about all the time that i made up
a long time ago
i started making it up through pain tell
them what that is what you go so
basically the 40
rule is i am a strong believer that we
quit because why how the
does a 297 pound cockroach guy right who
quit on everything
is now considered one of the best man on
the planet how is that possible
it means i had to change one thing my
mindset
so there's no way in hell that that was
it but that was
that guy was in me when that guy came
down here and said hey
guess what man you're a fat ass but i'm
gonna now make you a badass
i want a miracle this to be a badass no
it was in me i had to believe and make
that belief
work and through hard work i did that
so the 40 rule was like we have a like a
car
some cars have a governor on it and when
you get like 92 miles an hour that car
will start doing this because it can't
go any faster
those cars that don't have governors on
like like a fast ass whatever porsche
whatever
i'ma bury it dawn we have that abilities
but we
have put this governor on our minds
and you have to the factory that put the
governor on that car
the factory is now you that put this on
your mind you gotta take that
off until you take it off you're gonna
constantly get to 92 miles an hour and
do this
because you ain't growing faster yeah in
my fact you might even go slower
so basically i started realizing this
through my life through going through
all these times
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule
in what day what time and what place
you're going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
nobody wakes up every day and says this
is gonna be the greatest day ever
not dan lok not evan carmichael not tony
robbins
nobody you wake up and you're tired and
you have stuff in your eyes and you have
lines on your face from the pillows the
difference between successful people
is that they demand excellence from
themselves to the habits and routines
that they do
daily the problem is that thinking that
these people are different
that if you're not waking up with tons
of motivation ready to take on the day
that something is wrong with you the
only thing that's wrong with you is you
don't have the habits that set you up
for success every single day
and today i want to change that so i
have a
5s morning routine that i go through
every single day that sets me up for
success that demands excellence i'm
going to share with you guys today
the first s is sing the fastest way to
change your state
is to put on music the fastest way to go
from feeling low energy
tired bored into an energy of i am ready
to go
is music put on the song not that makes
you feel the current way that you're
feeling this is where most people mess
up you put on music for how you're
currently feeling if you're feeling
really sad and low energy
you're going to put on really mellow
slow music what does that do
it keeps you in the same state that
you're in it keeps you exactly where you
are
what you want to do is put on the music
for how you want to feel and so i have a
playlist on my main channel called the
believe playlist
which is the songs that i listen to
these are the songs that i listen to
every day they may work for you they may
not work for you there's no perfect song
for everybody there's a perfect song for
you and so build a playlist are the
songs that make you come alive
here's the criteria if this song came on
it would force you to start moving if
the song came on you find yourself doing
this
if the song came on you would get out of
your chair and want to move around
doesn't mean you're going to dance like
crazy doesn't mean you're going to start
building up the lyrics that may be you
awesome
but if you're a little more introverted
or don't like to dance something that
would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what i want
make a playlist and put that on it's the
first thing that you do
every single morning it'll make a huge
difference to setting the tone
changing your state and giving you
energy and momentum to start the day
s number two is sun i like getting
outside i think there's something about
getting outside of your home of your
condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature
makes a big difference getting some
getting some vitamins on your face
from the sun outside but also signifying
that you're you're leaving your bedroom
you're leaving
the condo the apartment the home you're
leaving what happened last night and
you're ready to go off and start the day
this is especially important if you're
working from home because it's easy to
have your you know office right next to
your bedroom or maybe your office is
your bedroom
and carry that bedroom energy that tired
i just woke up i want to stay in bed i
want to sleep
energy into your work and you won't do
great things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work
so having some kind of ritual that
splits up
sleeping energy to i'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and i find
the easiest way to do it
is to get outside and get some sun bonus
points if you're in a condor apartment
to take the stairs instead of the
elevator
s number three is sore and this is the
most important thing for me if you only
take
one of the five i think this is the most
important one to take
what is the thing that makes you sore
every day what's the thing that makes
you feel alive
bold confident what is that and put it
into your morning routine
at some point in your life you felt bold
you felt unstoppable you felt confident
it's happened to everybody
the problem is you don't feel that way
consistently every day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man i could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the
i don't know if i can do it i don't know
who am i to go do this crazy thing
that's the problem so whatever the thing
is that makes you feel like you can come
alive that gives you that boldness and
confidence
plan it with intention every single day
into your morning routine
for me what i do is i record a message
on my phone to to instagram to my
stories to
i put it to linkedin and twitter right
now i'm putting it everywhere but i need
to make a message
so i think of somebody that i helped
yesterday i think of somebody who
commented on a video who i met in person
who i coached on my instagram live
somebody that i helped yesterday and
then i make a message
channeling that person i won't say the
person's name but i have them in my head
i need to remind myself that the work
that i do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that
two to three hundred thousand people
watched my videos yesterday that's
crazy it's a wild number right it's wild
it's hard to
like what does that even mean i don't
know i'm just sitting here talking to a
camera
in my office and two to three hundred
thousand people are watching my videos
it's crazy
i need to think down to the actual
person i need to think about an
individual that this matters to somebody
that the work i do
really means something to them and then
i need to record a message and share it
that helps me soar and i do it every day
what is the thing for you
what makes you sore maybe it's watching
the 254 series that i put up
every day maybe it's watching the
espresso videos like this that i
put up every day and some people every
day this is part of the morning routine
is watch an espresso video and i'm
humbled to be a part of your morning
routine
for other people it might be meditating
they might be watching a video or might
be reading a book and listening to a
podcast
i don't care what the thing is but you
have felt bold
unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what
led you to feeling that way and then
demanded of yourself every day
by putting it into your morning routine
the third s is sore
it's the most important one the fourth
has for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and i want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout
a cardio workout a weights workout i put
that into my daily routine because i
want to bust a sweat and i want to
stay healthy into my 40s which is coming
up
and then into my 50s and beyond and then
the last
s for me is scare i want to do something
every day that scares me
what i'm doing right now is i take a
cold shower so after sweating i need to
have a shower they want to
show up to work all smelly and so hop in
the shower but
right away start turning the colder and
colder and colder and colder and colder
and then right at the very end i go all
the way cold and i freeze
and even just thinking about right now
it sucks
which is the best right you want to do
the thing that scares you every day
you're teaching yourself that i do scary
things
so whatever is scary for you whether
it's taking a cold shower whether it's
making a phone call whether it's sending
an email making a video and posting it
doing scary things teaching yourself
getting that out of the way right in the
beginning
i find really helps me
[Music]
if you want to learn how to hack your
life for success check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there